we'll get to that club
and thank you everyone this is just
fantastic to be here as I look in I
didn't realize we're gonna have all the
people up on the other floors it's
fantastic to see you all and people
behind me as well this is really really
brilliant I think this is the second
biggest audience we've had here since
the Queen the late Queen opened the
building so it is really really
fantastic to be here it's great for me
to be in Manchester
peace
I have to confess it is the first time
I've been here since a particular
football game last week
so I'm going to pass the usual Arsenal
jokes today
let's just say uh Lucy
the fight goes on
and actually that we can learn something
from Arsenal and from Man City
bear with me
because all the way to the end of the
season the objective for both teams is
the same win the league a goal that
could be achieved only by teamwork
Excellence a blend of skills different
people pulling together on and off the
pitch contributions big and small
tactics may change Lucy but the pursuit
is single-minded and the focus the
ambition the mission
that never changes
don't worry I'm not going to turn up to
Parliament in a track suit but
I do do believe Britain needs a clear a
sense of purpose and that the way we run
our country can be more like a brilliant
sports team pursuing victory
the government can be driven forward by
clear focused objectives
and that this approach is vital for
Britain to get its confidence its hope
and its future back
and that's what I'm here to set out
today how a new mission-driven labor
government will end sticking plaster
politics and in doing so get Britain
back on its feet
I will never accept that this country is
destined for decline that our best days
belong to the Past
success is all around us it just needs
Direction
people have huge Ambitions for their
community
they just need a government that matches
their ambition
and I I think there is a yearning to
come together to be part of something
bigger that appetite it's always been
there in all our big moments in our
history the creation of the NHS
during the pandemic in spades
passing of the late Queen last year
a pride and a purpose that we have to
unlock to drive our country forward
towards a better future
all around the world countries are
gearing up for An Almighty race for the
opportunities of tomorrow
Britain must be on the start line not
back in the changing room tying the
laces
some nation is going to lead the world
in offshore wind
why not Britain
some Nation will create the first
generation of quantum computers
why not Britain
some Nation will Design medicines
personalized to match our unique DNA why
not Britain
why not
because sticking plaster politics holds
us back
pick any of the current problems energy
security productivity immigration We
compare all day
but it wouldn't matter
the pattern is always the same
distracted by the short-term obsessions
that fixate Westminster
held back by a cynicism which uses low
trust in politics as an excuse to narrow
our Ambitions blinker to the potential
of an active government setting the
direction we Lurch from crisis to crisis
always reacting always behind the curve
a sticking plaster never a cure
just look at the NHS
for years we've had winter crises
every year the same Panic the same
despair
this is life and death and yet the
government has never found a long-term
solution
sticking plaster politics
the fundamentals never fixed
not one crisis but a cluster of Crisis
that compound each other combined to
send a nation in a downward spiral
the evidence that this has happened to
Britain is all around us
the only country in the G7 still poorer
than it was before the pandemic
the worst decade for growth in two
centuries
seven million on waiting lists and
Rising you don't see this everywhere
and and look
it's easy to blame it all on the Tories
but some of these problems go back
decades others are clearly aggravated by
events and I won't criticize this
government unfairly for the consequences
of the war in Ukraine
but over 13 years
by their actions
and crucially their inactions
the tourists have made Britain's
problems deeper longer lasting and more
painful than any of our competitors
seriously
ask yourself this
do I feel better off today than I did 13
years ago
what's the list of achievements they can
rattle off the legacy of our country
that they can be proud of
and the idea that the people who created
the mess around us are the right ones to
clean it up forget it
they're devoid of ideas they're clapped
out they're divided too weak to
challenge the vested interest in their
party which hold Britain back
too closed in on themselves to think big
for our country
Britain needs leadership with ambition
belief in the possibilities of the
future hunger to take on the big
challenges
this is the case for change
a new government and a new way of
governing Britain needs both with labor
Britain will get both
and that's what today is about
a Britain that gets its future back
and I'll tell you how
we're going to transform the way Britain
does its business from top to bottom
will modernize central government so it
becomes Dynamic agile strong and above
all focused
more open to expertise to partnership
with business unions communities and
Civil Society Mission driven government
foreign
focus on a clear set of priorities
an answer to the widespread call to fix
the fundamentals a long-term plan to
unlock our pride and our purpose a
profound statement of intent
mission-driven government
in some ways it's a it's a simple idea
every business around the world every
organization has a strategy a nation
needs one too
a plan a framework a compass that acts
as a guide for everything we do
making clear what is Mission critical
for my government
and what isn't
a Clarity that will ruffle feathers
across whitetall and Beyond
but one that is necessary
necessary to build Britain's long-term
strength necessary to Galvanize action
for change across the country
necessary because of what it can give to
businesses families and to working
people certainty and change stability
and success a plan for today and a more
secure future
and from this something
even more precious
of Britain once again on the front foot
with a sense of hope of possibility of
ambition
a Britain that gets its future back
five National missions
each one laser targeted on the complex
problems that drive our crises the root
causes that demand new thinking new
Solutions born in all parts of the
country
new ways of harnessing the Ingenuity
that's all around us
each Mission will come with clear
measurable outcomes Ambitions that won't
be overtaken by the future that raise
our sights and at first glance seem
too bold
invite a sharp intake of breath
a question
can this really be done
and then
when the doubts begin to subside
a new emotion
and a new determination
why not Britain
let me let me give you an example zero
carbon British electricity by 2030. a
huge goal which will allow us to
accelerate to Net Zero
make no mistake this goal would turn
Britain into a clean energy superpower
it will put us ahead of any major
economy in the world that's the shop and
take a breath by the way
and look
I'm already talking to CEOs investors
entrepreneurs unions energy workers
about how we get this done
the conversation always starts
with the shake of the head
this is a bit much Clear clean energy by
2030. that's going to be going some
but when I tell them
here's the ambition here's the plan and
here's the opportunity for you that is a
powerful urgency to make it happen
but it will only happen with the right
building blocks cheaper bills real
energy security independence from
tyrants like Putin and an industrial
strategy that can win the race for jobs
in the green industries of the future
now each of our five missions will
contain this formula
a measurable goal
the building blocks of a clear strategy
and the first steps of a credible
long-term plan
First Steps like the installation of 19
million homes
like training for people to be heat pump
Fitters Builders Engineers electricians
like GP energy a new British company
that will supercharge our drive for
cleaner energy
and taken together
lay a new foundation for prosperity in
every community
now today I want to focus on Labor's
mission for the British economy
because no mission is more important to
the future of our country
in the last year alone Rachel Reeves and
I have met thousands of Business Leaders
CEOs all over the country
leaders in retail in Hospitality Life
Sciences digital clean tech the creative
Industries
we've met workers on the shop floor and
those suffering profoundly from the cost
of living crisis right across Britain
and through all of this what we need has
become crystal clear
growth
economic growth is the oxygen for our
Ambitions the lifeblood of a strong
society and a successful economy our
living standards better Public Services
more hope and opportunity
without strong growth
these are just empty slogans
and let me spell it out if growth over
the last 13 years had been as strong as
under the last Labor government we would
have 40 billion pounds extra to spend on
schools of the NHS without a single
extra penny in tax
foreign
Britain needs to create more wealth
needs to be more competitive
it's that simple
now you may ask it's easy to want growth
so what's so different about you
well
I say
for 13 years there's been no plan no
urgency and no one with the courage to
do the hard yards that will change who
growth is for and where it comes from
so let me announce the economic mission
of the next Labor government
by the end of Labor's first term we will
deliver the highest sustained growth in
the G7
note that word sustained
this isn't growth on a graph this isn't
going to be gamed by clever statistics
this is going to be growth that makes
people better off higher living
standards
I want more growth in London of course I
do
but I'm not interested in a model of
growth where London races ahead and the
rest of the country stagnates
nor will I be satisfied if our growth
depends on creating jobs that are low
paid and insecure
we need growth from the Grassroots a new
model wealth created Everywhere by
everyone for everyone
so our mission on growth comes with a
second yardstick
it must be powered by good jobs and
stronger productivity in every part of
the country every part of the country
it's not just against that
the judges on our plan over the last
three years we've put the building
blocks in place
and we have those first steps necessary
but not sufficient
which can tackle the immediate problems
so when we say growth demands we unlock
the potential of every worker that we'll
get bring back to work and thriving once
it gets there
we can say the first steps are reforming
reforming apprenticeships a modern child
care system and a new deal for working
people that will make work pay
when we say drugs depends on seizing the
opportunities of tomorrow not falling
behind
on embracing Technology Innovation
science
we could say the first steps are a
reformed planning system a more powerful
British Business Bank that can support
startups to grow and scale
and a credible industrial strategy that
gets everyone around the table and
removes barriers to investment
when we say growth needs an economy that
is resilient to Global shocks and open
to global trade
that means we will use levers like
procurement to build up those Supply
chains that are critical for our
security
and we will fix the brexit deal and
reset our relationship with the EU
and when we say growth must now be built
on the contribution of every Community
every region Every Nation
that means we'll give communities the
right powers for robust private sector
growth to control their economic Destiny
stand on their own feet and put those
powers in our Take Back Control bill
and the one thing I need to be really
clear about these four shifts in
Britain's approach this new model
depend on a fifth
from chaos to certainty the rock of
economic stability
where policies are always fully costed
fiscal rules are sound unfollowed
rigorously constraints accepted
institutions respected not bypassed
and as a result
investors here and across the world have
the confidence and the certainty that
they need to get behind our missions
I look at what some of the tourists are
saying in the moment and I can't believe
they need to learn this lesson again
that they don't understand still
that chaos has a cost
the noises off you hear from them
they're a primal scream
the last gasp of a party caught between
a rock of stagnation and the hard place
of its economic recklessness
the message to the British people is
clear
labor is the party of fair growth labor
is the party of economic stability labor
is the party of ambition
that
certainty the security of good
government must always provide
without it mission-driven government
just won't work
you have to do the basics of course you
do
I look at a problem like our Asylum
system
and yes it needs a solution
it's incredible the government doesn't
have a plan
that they won't match our plans to set
up a dedicated NCA unit to deal with
this with specialist officers working
every day to take down the gangs and to
reach out across the channel to
countries who share this challenge
National Security but our borders in our
communities on the world stage is the
number one duty of government always
that's why I went to see President
zielinski last week
to underline the total solidarity of my
labor party towards his fight for
freedom
mission-driven government is about what
we do beyond that
how we restore our ambition
raise our sights above the quick fixes
the pandering to the noisy crowd the
short-termism that will only ever
provide the sticking plaster
but also how you bring our country
together open minds change how
government operates and the silos
it's about creating the conditions for
ambition to be realized for Pride to be
harnessed purpose to be unlocked
five National missions
Mission One Secured the highest
sustained growth in the G7 with good
jobs productivity growth in every part
of the country growth that makes
everyone not just a few better off
mission two
build an NHS fit for the future by
reforming Health and Care Services to
speed up treatment harness life sciences
and Technology reduce preventable
illnesses and cut Health inequalities
mission three
make Britain's Street safe by reforming
the police and Criminal Justice System
preventing crime early tackling violence
against women and girls and stopping
criminals getting away without
punishment
tough on crime tough on the causes of
crime now you've heard that before
but it's right
Mission four break down the barriers to
opportunity at every stage for every
child
by reforming Child Care reforming
education raising standards everywhere
and preparing young people for work and
for life
and five yes we will make Britain a
clean energy superpower
and these missions these five missions
will form the backbone of the labor
Manifesto the pillars of the next Labor
government
they will be measurable so we can track
progress and be held to account
long term so we can look beyond the
day-to-day
informed by experts in the public so we
can build a coalition for change
and each will support our drive for
growth
each will help us get our future back
but look
if we're going to make it work it will
need a totally new mindset
we have to understand that the how is as
important as the what
so we're going to ask different
questions of public servants and
ministers
difficult questions
how do we dissolve decision making to
those with real expertise on the ground
how do we bring people affected every
day by the issues we must solve Into the
Heart of our decision making
how to make sure that our Relentless
focus on the ends
goes alongside flexible creative and
Imagination about the memes
how do we change incentives
that we Embrace technology
rather than be afraid of the risks that
come with the new
and finally
one more question
that draws on my experience running the
crown prosecution service
how in everything we do
can we take a preventative approach
teaching problems early before they
fester and grow into something more deep
rooted
we will ask these questions
because I'm not interested in dancing
around issues or mouthing off about them
but in bringing people together with
purpose and intent
and look
when I say
everything will not be fixed just by
spending more money
that's not just because of the damage
the torahs have done to our economy or
because we think it's the responsible
thing to do
so all of that is true
it's because the more I delve into these
challenges the more I can see things
that are simply not working
things that could be sped up joined up
given Direction made to work better
this
is at the core of my politics government
can prevent problems as well as fix them
can shape markets rather than serving
them can lead a collective National
effort on growth and innovation
but without reforming the role of
government
none of that will happen
equally I have to say I'm not concerned
about whether investment or expertise
comes from the public or private sector
I just want to get the job done and I
mean that we have to get it done
there is a massive role for the private
sector in mission-driven government
but if the aspiration is merely to
replace the public sector while
extracting a rent
to privatize the profits whilst
socializing the risk
that takes us nowhere
mission-driven government is a different
way altogether
not State control or pure free markets
but a genuine partnership sleeves rolled
up working for the national interest
not command and control white all Knows
Best
but an approach that understands what
national renewal means change for all
from all
and that's the best thing about
mission-driven government you can't do
it without people
you can't grow the economy without
entrepreneurs creating new ideas
you can't make streets safe without
communities looking out for one another
you can't make healthier lives without
people changing their habits
change can come from Unlocking The Pride
and purpose of all of us
I grew up working class in a small town
and all my life I've seen potential
thrown away
people who don't get the respect that
they deserve
who feel invisible in their own country
I want to Britain where you don't have
to change who you are just to get on
a country where success belongs to
everyone and success comes from everyone
a future built by everyone everywhere
that's what our missions are about
change from the whole country National
renewal from a new National purpose
and that's my role in this as prime
minister my personal mission would be to
make mission-driven government a reality
to keep our eyes focused on the prize
so in the coming months for each Mission
the whole of the Shadow cabinet will be
supporting me
meeting with experts yeah we still
believe in them
um but also Frontline practitioners that
do as the thinkers the entrepreneurs the
innovators the British people
and we're going to ask them
what will it take what are the barriers
what needs to change to bring these
missions alive
and crucially
how do we make these missions a vehicle
for Hope for you your family your
community
how do we build a bridge from the
Britain we see around us
full of potential but short of Direction
to the fairer Greener more Dynamic
future our missions will deliver
that's the defining work of my labor
government and we will prepare for it
now there is no time to lose
I'm well aware that at a moment like
this it's it's hard to Hope
harder still to convince people that
they and politicians have a common cause
of course it is
people have listened to politicians and
pulled together before
they did it after the financial crash
when politicians made them pay for the
mess caused by Banks
they did it in the pandemic while the
government broke all the rules that they
were following
they might even have done it after
brexit
but nobody in charge could find the
words to ask
people are entitled to turn around and
say
why should we trust you
but I say to them the change you want
the Britain you want the better future
you want we can walk towards it together
every region and nation of the UK must
be heard
but we have to come together
National missions for National renewal
the fastest growing economy in the G7 a
clean energy superpower public services
that lift us up a mission-driven
government that will end sticking
plaster politics
we'll unlock the pride and purpose that
is in every community
will give this country its confidence
its hope its future back now is the time
for us all to be part of something
bigger and to say with one voice why not
Britain
thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much thank you
we're now
colleagues
we're not going to take various
questions from the media starting with
Beth from Sky News Beth hi and we're
going to try and keep this short and one
H best
thank you okay stormy you're 28 points
ahead in the polls reflecting voted
dissatisfaction with the current
government people want their country to
work but can you honestly say that your
Blue Sky Thinking rather than clear
specific policies such as cutting work
in people's taxes or ensuring that
they'll get a Hospital appointment is in
any way relatable
does this risk turn in off even anger in
people that you need to vote for you and
given that you've ditched policies such
as scrapping tuition fees and
nationalized and energy companies the
policies that you want the labor
leadership on why should anyone believe
anything you say anyway thank you uh
Beth look thank you for that question I
mean on this central question
um we we do tend to go round and round
you're quite right to say look what's
what are you going to do about the NHS
this winter what are you going to do
about energy bills
um this spring and we have to answer
that question I accept that and that's
why we do have answers to those
questions why we were the first to lead
on freezing energy bills but the problem
if we stop there with that sort of
retail offer for the here and now is
that we'll never fix the fundamentals
and therefore next year we'll be back in
an NHS crisis and you'll be sitting here
Beth and you'll ask me the same question
what are you gonna do about the here and
now and probably the year after and the
year after we go round and round in
circles sticking class to politics but
that's why we've got to fix it for the
NHS if we don't have more medical
students more nurses and doctors coming
through then we will never get out of
this cycle and therefore this long term
has to be harnessed with the short term
missions for a mission-led government
same on energy to be perfectly honest
freezing the bills this year and then
you'll come back next year and say well
we're going to freeze the bills next
during the year after
and the answer is we do have to do that
that's why we LED on that policy but we
also have to have a better answer for
energy security energy bills in the
future and that's why running toward
Renewables having our you know net
energy by Clean energy by 2030 is so
important and that's the frustration I
mean we've had 13 years of sticking
plaster politics we've had 13 years of
going round and round in circles always
ending up in the same place and never
moving forward and this is absolutely
needed and I do I reject the argument
that the public don't get it everybody
knows in their own life that you do fix
a problem when it comes to maybe your
pipes or your car or whatever it is but
everybody knows you've also got to fix
the fundamentals otherwise you'd just be
back in the same place at the end of the
exercise and that's what this is about
and you know all you've got you know
from the government frankly is sort of
short-term promises to clear up their
own mess these are long-term missions
for National renewal thank you Beth um
Chris
from BBC
on the on the trust issue look I think
anybody looking at these missions will
realize that they're hard thought
through they reflect the really big
challenges of the country and they come
each of them not just with the mission
which is really ambitious hard to
achieve but also with the underpinning
the specifics that are needed as to how
they're going to be achieved and
actually for each of them with the first
steps what are you going to do as it
were from day one and we'll set those
out obviously for the economy we've
already set them out for Net Zero we've
set them out and we'll do that for the
other missions thank you Beth Chris
thank you Chris Mason from BBC News
let's talk about one specific if we may
about economic growth what would you do
around corporation tax this April it's
due to go up should it go up plus if I
may what do you say to those who say
look you were elected on a particular
set of policies for the labor leadership
and you've jumped loads of those so why
should we believe what you're saying now
is something you'll stick to well Chris
on corporation tax
we haven't opposed the increase in tax
but I have to say and and I think this
will reflect anyone who's been talking
to CEOs and businesses as we've been
intensely for the last year or two we've
been sitting down and saying what is it
that inhibits growth where how do we
unlock this but I have to say in all
honesty very few of them say it's
corporation tax nearly all of them say
we don't have the basic security so
Global Investors are not saying we don't
have the money or the wherewithal to
invest that we don't have the ambition
what they say is we don't have these
circumstances of stability that would
allow us to go forward and
you know on a political level it's quite
funny and we joke about the fact we've
had three prime ministers and four
chancellors and four budgets last year
let's become a political joke for
investors for those people that help us
grow our economy they say well just at
the moment I'm not that interested in
investing in your country I don't see
the long-term plan I don't see the
missions I don't see a government that's
got the wherewithal to stick to the plan
and therefore I don't think that these
are conditions for growth and that's
what we're driving at here so yes you
know corporation tax is going to go up
but actually that isn't the thing that
most people are talking about or on the
um
program I mean when I stood for
leadership labor party I ended every
single hosting by saying everything
you've heard today won't happen if we
don't have a labor government and
therefore the single absolute Mission
has to be to get a labor government and
that's the basis on which I was elected
in
um and
um the vast majority of Labor members
and supporters are a hundred percent
behind what we're doing they really like
these missions and they want us to put
them into action and to do what I
promised when I stood as leader which is
to take our our party from the worst
general election defeat since 1935
into a labor Victory into a labor
government they desperately want that
because that's the whole point of the
labor party to form a labor government
to change lives thank you Chris
thank you um kirst armor obviously to do
any of this you have to win an election
and to win an election you have to
persuade voters that this will change
their lives immediately so what I want
to know is how all of this translates
into your immediate priorities if you
were to become Prime Minister what would
you do on day one well Anushka let me
take that head on because each of the
missions is about long-term change it's
about a decade of renewable but each of
them is underpinned then by the
specifics what do you need to achieve
that and what are the first steps along
that road you know whether that's
um for example on energy
insulating 19 million homes setting up
GB energy in health doubling the number
of medical students so we can actually
have the next cohort of course we also
have to have short-term answers they you
know the election's still very likely to
be what are you going to do about bills
particularly energy bills to which we've
got specific policy which is the public
a very very keen on but I I do reject
this idea that the public somehow don't
get it that you need to sit to fix the
immediate problem but also do the
fundamentals I'm really most I think
many many people so of course I want the
fundamentals if you could actually do
this if you've got a plan of what they
we've lost hope in plans this is a plan
this is a strategic plan these are
missions to the future we haven't had
that for the last 13 years and that's a
big part of the problem and therefore as
I say I don't I don't accept the sort of
basic proposition that the electorate
will simply say fix my bills for this
year and I'm not interested in anything
else of course we need to fix the bills
this year okay and I'm not shying away
from it but we also need to fix the
fundamentals otherwise what is
government for just to keep fixing the
problems and end up in five years in the
same place where you started then
another five and another five and we
don't progress as a nation and for 30
years we've been stagnating we've been
in a sort of Crouch position where we
almost lack the confidence now to even
face up to the challenges of the future
we've got to turn all that around thank
you Anushka Andy Andy Bell
thank you very much uh Andy Bell 5 News
um Kia stalmer isn't all this just
another way of saying to people sorry
there is no more money there are a lot
of people at home at the moment who
would like a labor government if there
is one to spend more money on the NHS on
the police on various other areas of
Public Services what you're saying to
them is actually what I have here in
missions and as for more money I'm
afraid you can forget that no Andy
that's not um right
um of course some of these will require
money and where we put money and we will
have it fully costed and set that out
um if we work in this way
um it will be a catalyst for unlocking
private sector money as well and
therefore this isn't all about how much
money from the treasury is needed to
make these missions work it's how do you
create the conditions in which the
public and the private sector can work
together but there's also something else
Andy and that is reform I've run a
public service for five years and I know
that if you put more money in your
public service you will get a better
outcome but you won't fundamentally
change it if you don't reform and that's
why reform is a big part of what we're
saying here on the Health Service on the
way we run the country the industrial
strategy reform has to be part of the
answer you know in criminal justice it
used to frustrate me we were in a silo
and you put more money in the top but it
might speed things up but in
fundamentally change
actually the outcome and so reform is as
important as the money we put in thank
you Andy I've got Henry from the times
Henry hi thanks
um last week you effectively barred
Jeremy corbyn from standing for labor
again uh when you said you were 100
behind making him prime minister were
you telling the truth and if you were
why should people who couldn't vote for
labor under his leadership trust your
judgment and if you weren't telling the
truth why should anyone trust that
you're going to stick to these missions
uh Henry look first let's be absolutely
clear about what I said about Jeremy
corbyn last week I said that he won't
stand at the next election as a labor
candidate that was as I was doing a
press conference for the equality and
Human Rights Commission where after over
two years having found us to be in
breach of the law they had concluded
that we'd done enough that our plans
were sustainable that they could take us
out of special measures and I said that
the labor party now is unrecognizable
from the labor party party of 2019 that
wasn't celebrating that we've been taken
out of special measures but I certainly
wasn't going to be going backwards the
last election you know like every labor
member and supporter of course I
campaigned for a labor government in the
same way that every tour he supporter
remember campaigned for a conservative
government but I recognized that the
electorate delivered their verdict on
labor in 2019 and that therefore the
first thing we if you in verdict like
that you don't sort of look at the
lecturer and say what were you doing
didn't you hear us you look at your own
party and say it's us that's got to
change thank you Henry Pippa
foreign
ER from the guardian
um here you said you want the highest
sustained growth in the G7
um brexit has hit economic growth by
billions of pounds since 2016. you said
today you'd fix brexit if you get into
government but exactly how
um Peppa
firstly
I think we have to confront the fact
that the lack of growth in our economy
can't simply be put down to brexit we've
had a problem with growth in our economy
since 2010 and a lot of this predates
brexit and therefore if we get fixated
that brexit is the only issue when it
comes to growth I think we'll be making
a big mistake I also and I'm not
pretending that we don't need to improve
the deal we've got with the EU but just
to put it into context secondly I'd say
that for many many investors
it's the stability that they are looking
for the non-trashing of the institutions
the idea that the labor government will
be a a government of sound money that's
what's making the difference in the
conversations that we are having
but I do think the brexit deal needs to
be improved I think if you look at the
deal we've got it's obviously not
working very well it wasn't oven baked
it wasn't even half baked
um it you know look at the impact we
have to have a closer trading
relationship not just fixing the
protocol in Northern Ireland but more
generally but as I say I think you know
the answer to growth can't be simply
laser focused on brexit and what I said
about growth I just want to reinforce
this paper is it has to be growth
everywhere across the whole of the
country there is a model of growth that
says you supercharged London and
Southeast and I don't want London the
southeast held back but I don't want my
ambition for labor government is that
you sue you have loved in the Southeast
and then sort of redistribution for
everywhere else I think that is totally
the wrong model it is totally
disrespectful our ambition is for growth
in every single place across the United
Kingdom not just London the south east
not just Manchester I love the growth in
Manchester it's really good but I want
growth in every town around Manchester
as well and the same for every city
across the country thank you Pippa Amy
from the telegraph
y
sorry begum case you've said you support
the courts blocking her return so would
labor ensure that other former jihadists
do not return as well look at National
Security has to come first the court has
looked at all of the material and come
to a very firm conclusion and I support
what the court has done but under a
labor government National Security will
always come first and that's why in my
speech I said that if you like the
mission sit in a basket of economic
stability of strong borders but also of
strong National Security thank you very
much David from the mail
uh thank you um you just briefly
mentioned the Asylum system but the
issue of small boats crossing the
channel
doesn't feature as one of your main five
missions uh by contrast the PM's
five-point plan includes a very clear
pledge to stop the boats
um what's the thinking behind not making
it one of your main missions given that
it's an important issue for voters yeah
David thank you for that question as I
set out in my speech
um
absolutely fundamental they are the
fundamentals of good government the
missions about what you do beyond that
but it's absolutely clear you need to
have secure borders and if you're going
to have secure borders you need to have
a plan and we've set out time and again
what our plan is the most important bits
being actually getting the Asylum system
to work processing the claims when I
first learned that of all the people
that arrive by boat in 2021 only four
percent have had their claims processed
I was really shocked and I think anybody
else would be really sure that's a
broken system broken by this government
but if you really want to do the fixing
bit then you do need a new unit within
the NCA extra officers to do the
cross-border control I I worked well as
director of public prosecutions we
formed cross-bordered teams to deal with
you know drugs being taken over borders
guns being taken over borders why can't
we do the same in relation to the gangs
that are dry driving those into
desperate situations into those boats so
it's absolutely Central it's a given for
me we've already set out a plan for it
frankly if the government picked up our
plan we might make some progress thank
you David Ashley from the mirror
actually Calvin from the mirror
um Jeremy corbyn said in his first
planned speech outside number 10 the one
that didn't happen that he would have
announced an end to homelessness in
Britain and pledging to end Russ
sleeping within a week is that something
you could commit to and secondly the
team in front of you today the shallow
cabinet can you rule out the shadow
cabinet reseller before the next general
election
um
well let's deal with a second uh I
I don't know any leader of any political
party that would stand on a platform
like this and announce anything that
could conceivably be construed to be
um the beginning of a um reshuffle but
look
um
on homelessness of course we want to end
homelessness but uh you know that isn't
going to happen if we don't achieve
these missions if we don't get that sort
of economic growth if we don't fix our
Health Service we know that homelessness
is bound up with mental health and young
people in Desperate place so ending
homelessness is you know a a laudable
aim but what I'm in the business is of
how are you going to do it how do you
have to fix the country to make sure
that actually happens and
um and since I'm on this actually
they're gonna go with this because since
I've been in policy I've met so many
people who eloquently describe a problem
brilliantly describe a problem
I want to know how you fix it how you
actually change the country for the
better roll your sleeves up and have a
mission-driven government and so that's
the approach we're taking with these
five missions Chloe the from the eye
Chloe
Batman eye newspaper you said you want
to reform child care what is currently
under consideration with that and do you
think Universal free or low-cost Child
Care would be
um a good return we'll bring a good
return on investment of public money
yeah look on Child Care thank you Chloe
for that because it's really important
um because Child Care
um unlocks not just the potential of
children
um but also the potential of parents
particularly women parents in order to
get back to work
etc etc so Child Care is Central
um to our missions it's Central to not
just removing the barriers to
opportunity for every child but also to
economic growth what we've already
committed to is child care that covers
breakfast clubs the early part of the
day obviously you know that's that's a
first step there's more that needs to be
done but Child Care is Central to our
plans for all the reasons I've just
given Jack from the Sun Jack hi Jack oh
yeah thanks again in your speeches now
and in the questions you made a big
issue of trust um can we Circle back to
that because many people will watch you
selling out your five missions a day and
think well hang on didn't you believe in
a second random until he was a brexiteer
and he wanted to make Jeremy corbyn
prime minister as we've heard until he
said that there's no place in politics
for him as we're here today you now
actually believe that Shema begum
shouldn't come back to the UK so today
can you make a proper guarantee to
readers and voters that if you do exceed
to the highest office in the land there
will be no more flip-flopping well look
Jack
um we've got to remember that on things
like the second referendum we've been
through three years of a parliament it
was completely stuck and unable to find
a way forward which didn't have
leadership because the conservative
government did Reach Out across the
parliament he had a prime minister who
had a majority went to the country and
lost the majority and their whole party
imploded but as we go forward look these
are our missions this is our way of
working and I'm very happy to have that
tested if anyone wants to know to the
public trust and want any of this then
there's a very good way to find out
let's have a general election
foreign
I I will put my five long-term missions
for National renewal a decade of
national renewal up against Rishi sunax
five promises to clean up his own mess
and and the public can decide which of
those they want thank you Jack Jennifer
from the ft
hi um
yeah
um you talk uh you talked about not
wanting to Simply see the charge of
London in the south east uh as part of
your growth model
um for many people that that would sound
a little bit like treasury's sort of
traditional way of thinking about things
and uh treasury Orthodoxy has been
criticized as a barrier to growth by
everyone from let's dress to Ronnie
Burnham so I wondered whether you agreed
that there is a cultural problem in the
treasury and what would you what would
you change about it in order to hit your
growth Target and just quickly would you
also consider as part of your growth
plan a kind of Joe Biden style massive
injection of State aids to
post-industrial areas thanks uh Chad
look thank you very much for that um
question
on this question of growth and where we
have growth this is crucially important
because I think that unless it's growth
economic growth in every part of the
country
um it is meaningless for millions of
people
um and until now most people when
politicians talk about economic growth
think well that's all very nice but it
won't be anywhere near me and we have to
change that and that means that we have
to be bold enough to push power and
resources and decision making away from
Westminster and Whitehall that's why we
launched the Gordon Brown Commission on
the future of the UK in the latter part
of last year that is about making sure
that people with skin in the game make
decisions about what happens in their
area the the conditionality that comes
with that is it's got to go another plan
that's actually going to work and it
can't just push a sort of london-based
problem somewhere else so what I don't
want to see in Manchester is Manchester
City Center doing well but the outlying
towels not so much and the versions of
this across the country and so that will
only come if we're brave enough to do
what we set out in that Commission on
the future of the UK as for
Biden I mean Biden is pushing ahead with
Net Zero in a way which is causing the
EU and other countries to look up and
say well how do we in fact how our own
plans that match that and what we're
setting out today does match that in
terms of the ambition but where there is
money it will be the same old answer
from me which is everything we do will
be fully costed will be set out but this
is not all about public money if we
can't use these missions to unlock the
private sector then they won't work but
that's why we've already been talking to
the private sector I've already had hard
discussions with CEOs across you know
the world and in this country what will
it take what do you want to see from a
government that will actually unlock the
potential of this country thank you
Joseph from the Manchester Evening News
Joseph now doing Jen's old job not quite
um so the match Evening News has been
campaigning for new rules forcing social
landlords to fix damp and mold within
strict time limits uh following the
tragic death of two-year-old hour of
ishak in Rochdale and will the labor
party support our campaign for our absor
which has been tabled as an amendment to
the social housing regulation bill in
Parliament and what would you do in
government to make sure that such a
tragedy doesn't happen again yeah um
look Joseph thank you for raising that
because I think everybody when we saw
that case was absolutely shocked but of
course we have to support whatever
measures are necessary to make sure that
that doesn't happen again and I hark
back to my previous Life as a lawyer I
saw I don't know how many cases where I
was representing
um people in rented accommodation who
were putting up with damp because we
took action The Damp was abated for a
bit but nobody fixed the fundamentals
and so we're back with other cases over
and over again and that's why it has to
be part of a mission-driven government
to change this but um Joseph look we do
support whatever measures are necessary
and then Dan from Politico
uh you spoke earlier in the Q a about a
decade of renewal apart from your Pledge
on GDP which you've spelled out a time
scale for do you need two terms to
achieve the missions you've set out
today or can they be completed and
measured after five years
uh Dan thank you for that look I'm
pretty humble about this we lost badly
in 2019 and my ambition is to take the
labor party back into power that will be
an incredible journey if we're able to
do it and I'm mindful that every single
vote has to be earned and we've got a
long long way to go
but I'm also honest enough to say that
some of these issues are not going to be
fixed within five years they're longer
term than that these missions come with
measurable goals along the way the
underpinning and the specific First
Steps that'll put us on that Journey but
I don't think it'll come a surprise to
anyone that some of these issues are
going to be longer term that's why we've
said a decade of national renewal now
I'm not getting ahead of myself because
I am humble about this I do know that
every single vote has to be earned I do
know we've got a long long way to go
and you know that what we have to say
has to be put before the electorate and
we have to persuade them but at the same
time I'm not going to shy away from the
fact that after the damage that's been
done in the last 13 years it is going to
take time to fix the fundamentals what
I'm proud to do today is to set out a
plan that explains what are the changes
we want to see and how are we going to
do the fixing of the fundamentals thank
you all very much indeed thank you for
being here thank you for those of us
standing
thank you so much